we're going to look at Obamacare
basically the opposite of this photo
which is more Obama don't give a
two weeks ago we devoted around twenty
minutes to Republicans efforts to repeal
and replace that bill and the reason we
have to talk about it again tonight is
this breaking news overnight Republicans
revealed our long-awaited replacement
for Obamacare House Republicans roll out
a revamped health care plan it is
finally here oh yes the Republican plan
to replace Obamacare is public this is
the American Health Care Act yes it's
finally here the American Health Care
Act you may not have wanted it it looks
awful but it's here anyway so I think of
it as the legislative equivalent of
Pirates of the Caribbean 5 the curse of
Johnny Depp getting divorced and eating
the money as will be the case with that
movie the early reviews of this thing
have been rough this thing is probably
done on a rival conservatives hate their
bill I promise you Obamacare light dead
on arrival
it seems dead on arrival it's get on
arrival they're calling it a sticking
pile of garbage
well that would I mean I was wearing a
dead on arrival yes much like the life
behind Melania Trump sighs the ACA looks
dead by the time it was introduced in
Washington and there is no doubt the
bill got enemies quickly the American
Medical Association the American
Hospital Association the American Nurses
Association and the AARP all immediately
came out against it and even people you
would presume would be happy about the
repeal we're not exactly thrilled let me
show you what was the front page of
Breitbart this morning Freedom Works
opposes speaker Ryan's Obamacare 2.0
plan and I don't think Selina they mean
that in a nice way yeah I don't think
they do either I'm pretty sure they mean
it in the sense of Ryan is a beta male
snowflake who needs a safe space with
Cox services bill kind of way
essentially it means people on both
sides see the AHCA is just being shitty
Obamacare the way old Navy is a shitty
version of the gap and the way Easter
let's be honest 220 just be called
shitty Christmas
only one month kill shitty Christmas
everyone what are you asking for it had
better be a basket full of beans because
that's what you're getting but here is
the thing this bill is not actually dead
on arrival there is still a chance it
could become law so given that we need
to take a look at what is actually
inside this thing and let's start with
one of the big changes as we anticipated
it gets rid of Obamacare insurance tax
credits which are based on many factors
including income and they've replaced
that with a flat tax credit based on age
here is how it works
the proposal provides tax credits to
help pay for premiums someone under the
age of 30 would get $2,000 someone 50
and older would get $4,000 okay so the
older you get the more money you get
that's easy to understand think of it as
the exact opposite of being a woman in
Hollywood now so as we discussed two
weeks ago the key question here is do
the size of those credits sufficiently
cover the actual cost of health
insurance all are you left like a
middle-aged man in a thong horrifically
undercover and to help answer that
question I'm sorry can we just take that
down
thank you that's much better shut up
after that question the Kaiser Family
Foundation made a tool showing you how
you might be impacted by this new bill
based on your age income and location if
I could choose your own adventure game
for a very specific type of child if
your kid likes Caillou he will love this
interactive map of tax credits from the
Kaiser Family Foundation so let's say
you live in Wood Wood County Oklahoma
you're 60 years old and you earn say
fifty thousand dollars a year under
Obamacare you get thirteen thousand
three hundred and fifty dollars towards
insurance but under the new bill that
will drop down to just four thousand
dollars that is over two thirds less and
it's not one of those two-thirds
decreases that you barely notice like
when Robin and Barry of the Bee Gees
died I'm kidding I'm kidding
Barry is fine Robin and Morris are dead
Oh Robin the point is they are although
to be fair I have no idea you don't
either and I don't think either one of
us googling anytime soon
but that is really just one example
there are a lot of people who would be
harmed by the switch to these flat tax
credit and experts say one thing is
pretty clear here those who are lower
income would be particularly hurt and
that is before we even get into Medicaid
the program that largely provides health
care to poor and disabled Americans
because that is where this bill gets
really vicious and you know the changes
to Medicaid are rough just from how
creepily enthusiastic Paul Ryan sounds
talking about them let me just describe
exactly what this bill does for
conservatives this is what I'm so
excited about and this is why I think
people need to see the forest of the
trees we are D federalizing in
entitlement block reading it back to the
states and capping its growth rate
that's never been done before he is
rock-hard talking about that somehow you
can actually hear his direction during
that and if you don't know what he's
talking about that just sounds like a
benign pile of words but when he says D
federalizing block granting and capping
what that means in layman's terms is
cutting the living out of Medicaid
according to one analysis the plan would
cut at least 370 billion in federal
funding for Medicaid over the next 10
years now what that means is that states
would have to make up that gap to
maintain current levels of coverage
which for many of them will be next to
impossible so when they don't millions
of the poorest Americans will lose
coverage millions and I literally just
heard Ryan getting another erection when
I said those words and when you combine
that with the insufficient tax credit an
estimated 6 to 15 million people are
projected to lose insurance but to hear
Republicans like jason Chaffetz tell it
there's an easy solution you know what
Americans have choices and they've got
to make a choice and so maybe rather
than getting that new iPhone that they
just love and they want to go spend
hundreds of dollars that maybe they
should invest in their own health care
that is complete
and it's frankly a little hard to take a
lecture on making good choices from a
man who presumably entered a barber shop
and said give me the wet poodle Pierre
make it look like this font oh I took
exclusive its insurance cost as much as
an iPhone we wouldn't even be having
this debate people are going to be hurt
by this bill and those hit the hardest
who stand to lose $5,000 or more under
the new plan are ironically a group that
voted for Trump by a huge margin which
is pretty frustrating it's like if the
people of Pompeii voted for the volcano
I know you get to define your own
self-interest but I wish you hadn't
voted for that volcano so look if this
bill is bad for older Americans poor
Americans and many Trump supporters and
all these groups oppose it who exactly
is it for wealthy Americans are set to
get a sizeable tax break under the GOP
health care bill and the ultra wealthy
will see an even bigger tax cut some of
those in the top 1% of incomes will get
a tax break of around $33,000 those in
the top 0.1% will get an average tax cut
of about $197,000 under the GOP plan Wow
indeed so this plan is literally taking
money from the poor and giving it to the
very rich it's essentially a reverse
Bernie Sanders which is actually also
the name of a sex act consisting of very
aggressive fingering
it is not just literals uncomfortable
with this idea this week Paul Ryan paid
a visit to Tucker Carlson second second
chance attempt at his own TV news show
with Tucker Carlson and found himself
under attack kind of a hard sell to say
yeah we're going to repeal Obamacare but
we're going to send more money to people
have already gotten the richest over the
last 10 years I mean that's what this
does no I'm not left justit's just
that's true
I'm not elected that's true Ryan's plan
is so harsh it just caused a forty
seven-year-old boy man in a bowtie named
Tucker to worry about seeming overly
sympathetic through the fall and before
you point out the Tucker Carlson isn't
wearing a bow tie he is just not where
you can see and it is not just Tucker
here many Republican governors and
members of Congress have expressed real
concern that this bill is going to
actively hurt their state while on the
other hand amazingly those on the far
right wing of the party like congressman
mo Brooks of Alabama think it's way too
generous this far away is the biggest
welfare program ever sponsored and fight
frankly it undermines the work ethic it
increases greater reliance on welfare
from the federal government ultimately
it's going to result in the demise of
our country or at least contribute to
our debilitating insolvency and
bankruptcy so this bill seems almost
universally hated in Washington it is
truly the Ted Cruz of health care
legislation you Ted you
the white house clearly has a tough soil
job ahead and their efforts so far have
been less than impressive just watch
White House press secretary and breakout
star of bridesmaids Melissa McCarthy
deploys some visual aids for all of the
people who have concerns about this
especially on on the right look at the
side this is the Democrats this is up
there is I mean that you can't get any
clearer in terms of this is government
this is not oh she's a national treasure
but the seconds anything most
aggressively stupid thing I've ever seen
and I just saw jason Chaffetz against
paying for health insurance by retro
actively not buying an iPhone and that
low page count starts to get actively
worrisome when you find out what they
spent a decent amount of time in they're
focusing on the Republican plan contains
a section devoted to making sure people
receiving government health care
assistance who win the lottery are
removed from the program in an orderly
fashion in fact six pages of this bill
is devoted to letting states disenroll
high dollar lottery winners so a not
insignificant percentage of this bill is
focused on the urgent matter of what if
one poor person suddenly becomes less
poor I'm honestly surprised they didn't
also have a section covering what would
happen in the event of a Freaky Friday
type situation if the Medicaid recipient
Freaky Friday did to the body of an
individual living above a hundred thirty
eight percent of the federal poverty
line states are obligated to D enroll
recipients until recipient Freaky Friday
back using wish or magic not otherwise
specified all freaky Fridays into an
eligible body and yet despite all of
this Republican leaders are ferociously
trying to jam this bill through already
it has been introduced in the house and
passed by two committees and and yet
there is one personal you you may have
noticed I haven't actually mentioned so
far and that is Donald Trump and the
reason he's been largely absent from our
story is that he's been largely absent
from this story in general because
putting aside the prop comedy of the
star of Mike & Molly
John White House has been pretty
hands-off with this bill
and is there really any way deep down
the Trump has actually read this thing
given that he recently said this we have
come up with a solution that's really
really I think very good now I have to
tell you it's an unbelievably complex
subject nobody knew that healthcare
could be so complicated everybody knew
what really everybody if the one thing
people know about health care it's
complicated
before you say who knew King Tut was
dead everybody did these are said is
very Morris or Robin Gibb
or all of them or none of them there's
no way to find out Trump has been
noticeably distant from this whole
process and perhaps nothing shows that
more than how this bill is being branded
is it by any other name from care I'll
call it I'll call it the drum care if
you want to but I don't I didn't hear
President Trump say to any of us hey I
want my name on that holy son is not
clamoring to put his name on this bill
and he's put his name on some of the
shittiest products in human history he
put his name on a vodka even though he
doesn't drink whose slogan was success
distilled which was discontinued he put
his name on Trump toys which look like
the answers of the question it's a
reptile dysfunction was a fabric what
purpose would it be he even slapped his
first and last names on Donald Trump jr.
a man who looks like a six year old
drawing of a mean bank teller once not
wanting his name on the healthcare bill
he's like Tyler Perry not wanting his
name anywhere near Jew Ahmadiyya
Hanukkah
but well you know what I can kind of
understand Trump not wanting his name on
this it contains almost nothing that he
promised as Laura Ingraham pointed out
this week on Fox & Friends the trumpism
of the healthcare reform that the Trump
II aspartic were transparency and
pricing competition across state lines
and even on the edges you know repealing
the mccarran-ferguson act where is that
in this plan oh I'll tell you it's not
in there he is pushing a health care
bill that is missing a lot of what he
said he wanted and that is the kind of
top-shelf deal-making that you can read
all about in his best-selling book the
art of the wait what was the deal I
wanted against all I forget well anyway
let's talk about how hot my daughter is
right fellas husband Larry notice that
criticism because shortly after the
segment aired he tweeted don't worry
getting rid of state lines which will
promote competition will be in phase two
and three of health care rollout and
then as if to eliminate any doubt as to
whether he was watching Fox and Friends
he ended the tweet at Fox & Friends and
by the way it's just just about that
buying across state lines business Trump
and Ryan keep promising that it's just
around the corner but two things you
should know one it probably won't lower
prices in fact these three states
currently allow it but not a single
out-of-state insurer has taken them up
on the offer which does actually make
sense because if you're an insurer in
Massachusetts it takes a massive amount
of time and investment to set up new
networks of doctors and hospitals in
Maine and that's assuming Maine even
have doctors I think it's mainly beavers
with stethoscopes up there so so this
this state line thing is something
people love to talk about in theory but
no one really wants to do in practice
like apple picking or shower sex but but
the even bigger issue is it's almost
certainly not going to happen the state
line and a lot of other things
Trump has promised I'm not in this bill
because they cannot be as Paul Ryan well
knows interstate shopping across state
lines we love that policy we think it's
critical but as you well know
you cannot put that in a budget
reconciliation bill otherwise it could
be filibustered exactly he is right for
procedural reasons this is being
presented as a budget bill which
Republicans can't pass with a simple
Senate majority any non budget related
policy change requires 60 votes to beat
a filibuster so that is pretty much a
dead end meaning that this bill is in
all likelihood all Trump can get passed
to replace Obamacare so it is
important everyone understands what is
in it and that the something terrific
that he promised better coverage lower
costs no one losing their health
insurance well this bill is not it the
bill Trump is championing will act
actually increased costs for older poor
Americans and will cause millions of
people to lose coverage somebody needs
to explain this to him and since he is
clearly still watching Fox and Friends
we might actually be able to help here
because because you might remember at
last month we bought time on that show
to have our catheter cowboy explain to
him what the nuclear triad is well
saddle up partner for tonight you ride
again who better to tell from what they
feel water than someone who stands to be
hurt by it someone in his 60s in rural
America with an unspecified medical
problem that requires constant treatment
please enjoy the fad which will air on
thoughts and friends in the DC area on
Wednesday morning the tension catheter
patients hi me again I'm a professional
cowboy and I use catheters been cowboy
in for 25 years and there's two things I
know I don't like pain when I can and
healthcare is a complicated business
everybody knows that literally everybody
also if my premiums go up and subsidies
go down I'm going to wind up paying more
that's basic math there fella
that's like replacing my catheter with a
garden hose
I don't want that I do not like pain
when I cap the point is if that happens
millions of folks like me might get real
angry which is we're thinking about if
you're the sort of person who really
likes being popular you get that right
right you get that right right you get
that right